the niece is in Maryland hi Denise
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
how are you better than I deserve what's
up I been married 41 years since a man I
am 61 and he is 65 we've done a lot of
dumb things and we've also had a lot of
blessings I found you in January of 2018
I personally went through financial
peace he did not he has slowly gotten on
board we're on every dollar I canceled
stop there I cancelled them stopped our
IRA contributions like you said and
we're that are three to six months worth
of emergency money to decide he gets a
pension from Weber retirement I had
planned on starting back up with our
IRAs
but he recently had heart surgery so I'm
one and the bills are gonna start coming
in so I should I start that should I
change the baby steps do you have any
idea what the bills will be ah at least
20% of yeah whatever it was so probably
we don't know probably 20 or $30,000
twenty thirty thousand dollars anyway
coming your way right that's what I'm
guessing you know okay and what's your
household income total about 35,000 a
year yeah you need to stop everything in
pile up cash to get ready for these
medical bills if you're gonna have a
$30,000 hit-making 35,000 okay you don't
have any other money saved other than
your emergency fund
yeah yeah we gotta get ready for this I
mean we know the storms coming we just
don't know exactly what the arrival date
is right right this is not it's not a
theory it's happened and the bills are
gonna come
correct he's on he turned 65 so we went
on Medicare okay well you've just got to
ascertain what the actual out-of-pocket
is going to be and try to save that as
fast as you can and as soon as you save
that then you restart your other stuff
and because it's going to kill your
ability to save right you just to really
watch what you're doing so you're not
working anymore
y'all just living off of his retirement
no I I make about twenty thousand years
in his retirement 15 he his retirement
15 a month and he works our jobs okay
all right so you're not 35,000 you're
more like 40-something if you're making
20 and he's making 18 that's 38 okay
right I'm sorry
that's okay and then your side jobs on
top of that sup over 40 so but either
way you still don't have you know
$250,000 coming in or something like
that and you don't have a big pile of
money and you got a $20,000 bill coming
at least yeah so we've got a you know
what you might do is talk with the docs
and maybe even the hospital and try to
try to figure out what you're going to
get billed for even talk to your
insurance company and try to figure out
what you're going to get billed for but
in the meantime we know it's going to be
a bunch and you need to just stop
everything and pile up some cash to get
ready for it as fast as you can as soon
as you can get that behind you then you
get back to saving towards your nest egg
because you're debt-free and you know
you're building your your beyond the
emergency fund so you're building your
nest egg and getting your house paid off
for your next two goals